zdf heute live herzlich willkommen von
einer zeitenwende hatte bundeskanzler
scholz gesprochen jetzt vollzieht sie
auch die nato als reaktion auf die
bedrohung durch russland wird die nato
größer durch die erweiterung mit
finnland und schweden und sie wird
stärker mehrere tausend zusätzliche
soldaten wollen die usa auf europäischem
boden stationieren und die schnelle
eingreiftruppe wird von 40.000 auf
300.000 soldatinnen fast verachtfacht
heute zur eröffnung des nato gipfels in
madrid sprechen wir über diese themen
mit unserem korrespondenten vor ort
das ist im at wissen er ist live für uns
in madrid und gesprächen mit dem
ehemaligen nato general egon ramms
schönen guten abend an sie beide wir
schalten später auch noch maskiert zu
unserem korrespondenten der vor ort über
die sicht der ukraine auf die lage der
dinge berichten wird und verschaffen uns
jetzt aber allgemein einen überblick
über das was die nato vor hat was die
neue nato ist florian 9
er hätte diesen gipfel auch scheitern
lassen können doch schon bevor der
türkische präsident erdogan heute seinen
platz im sitzungssaal sucht hat er sein
veto gegen den nato beitritt schwedens
und finnlands zurückgezogen zufrieden
mit zusicherungen der beiden etwa dass
die bisher geltende beschränkungen für
waffenlieferungen in die türkei aufheben
und so können sich die nato spitzen
heute um anderes kümmern ihre neue
strategie
unser neues konzept macht klar dass
russland die bedeutendste und direkteste
bedrohung für unsere sicherheit ist im
bisherigen konzept galt russland noch
als strategischer partner
vom partner zur bedrohung worauf die
nato mit einer historischen aufrüstung
reagiert die schnelle eingreiftruppe
soll von derzeit 40.000 auf 300.000
soldaten fast verachtfacht werden
deutschland wird eine eigene brigade
über 1000 soldaten bereit halten die
schnell nach litauen verlegt werden
können andere nato hatten soll in diesem
deutschen modell folgen
wir werden unsere zusammenarbeit auch
verbessern indem wir die staaten im
östlichen bereich der nato besser
schützen mit einer besseren
zusammenarbeit und mit mehr truppen was
folgt sind weitere versprechen dass des
us-präsidenten die 100.000 us soldaten
in europa weiter zu verstärken und das
der nato an den ukrainischen präsidenten
sein land weiter mit waffen zu
unterstützen
kann sich auf uns verlassen so lange wie
nötig
die nato richtet sich in madrid neu aus
stellt die weichen auf erweiterungen
richtung norden und auf abschreckung
richtung osten
wir freuen uns auf ihre und eure fragen
und kommentare wie immer in die
kommentare oder wenn ihr die app nutzt
an zdf heute.de zdf.de immer beginnen
wir bei dir erleben wir so etwas wie die
wiedergeburt der nato heute
ja ich glaube das kann man so sagen man
hat ein gemeinsames jedoch das geht
eigentlich weit über russland und der
ukraine krieg hinaus das ist eben dem
autoritär ismus weltweit die stirn zu
bieten dafür sind heute eine menge
signale gestellt worden das eine ist
natürlich die verstärkung der
truppenpräsenz die amerikaner auch mit
sehr sehr starken ankündigen
ankündigungen am heutigen tag aber es
geht darüber hinaus man will klarmachen
dass der autoritarismus sich offenbar
verbündete russland mit china sehr engen
darauf bei zusammenarbeitet die rechte
basierte weltordnung zu untergraben so
steht es in der strategie neuen
strategiepapier der nato und deshalb
will man gegenhalten und stellt sich
entsprechend auf nicht nur mit dem
bündnis hier innerhalb europas das
transatlantische bündnis sondern auch
das pazifische bündnis an dem die usa ja
auch beteiligt sind und deswegen waren
ja heute auch japan südkorea australien
und neuseeland mit dabei immer hier
kommt direkt eine frage an dich aus dem
chat tom frank fragt über youtube
deutschland stellt neu 15.000 soldaten
woher kommt der rest
285.000 das stimmt was nicht selbst wenn
die usa
100.000 beisteuern ich nehme an das
bezieht sich auf die schnelle
eingreiftruppe kannst du da antworten
geben
genau es geht um die schnelle
eingreiftruppe und ehrlicherweise hat
uns keiner heute darauf antworten geben
können die ist ja bisher mit 40.000
soldaten vorgesehen die eingreiftruppe
sie soll jetzt eben verachtfacht werden
mehr als verachtfacht woher all die
soldaten kommen ist noch völlig offen
das ist heute nicht mit bekannt gegeben
worden aber die nato wird diesen worten
taten folgen lassen müssen denn sonst
wäre sie ja nicht glaubwürdig kommen wir
zur türkei wie hoch ist der preis den
das den die allianz zahlen musste damit
die türken die finnen und die schweden
bei treten lassen
also das eine ist ja die vereinbarung
die gestern unterzeichnet worden ist von
schweden und finnland zusammen mit der
türkei man hat offenbar pakete gemacht
also die unterschiedlichen forderungen
der türkei in mehrere teile aufgeteilt
und hat sich versprochen dass man
weitere daran arbeitet hat auch ein paar
zusagen gemacht es wird natürlich im
hintergrund vermutet dass es in
allererster linie der türkei ja um
militärische und wirtschaftliche hilfen
geht schweden wird also die militär
lieferung die rüstungslieferungen wieder
aufnehmen an die türkei die waren vor
einigen jahren eingestellt worden und
der amerikanische präsident war offenbar
gestern doch unmittelbar an den
verhandlungen beteiligt er hat gestern
im laufe des tages einmal mit erdogan
telefoniert er hat dann abends als man
hier in madrid zusammen saß dann auch
noch mal per telefon zumindest mit
schweden und finnland geredet wir hören
aus dem weißen haus es habe dabei keine
weiteren zugeständnisse gegeben also
nicht alle forderungen erdogan seien
erfüllt worden aber wir hören auch das
ganz offenbar die modernisierung der f
16 kampfjets die die türkei bereits hat
das scheint auf einem weg zu sein da ist
man zuversichtlich dass das durchkommt
also vielleicht war auch das teil des
deals damit die türkei am ende zustimmen
eine ganz kurze frage gerade noch an
dich bevor wir zu hören rams gehen
stimmt es eigentlich dass teil des
forderungspaket der türken war das im
offiziellen nato englisch turkey nicht
mehr turkey heißt wie die übersetzung
von truthahn sondern jetzt tobt hier
oder oder ähnlich ist das ist das ein
fake oder war das tatsächlich teil der
verhandlung
nein das war nicht teil der
verhandlungen
das ist schon vor zwei wochen glaube ich
wenn ich mich recht erinnere gelöst
worden die türkei hat das tatsächlich
gefordert sie wollte das eben offiziell
ihr name verändert wird hat ein bisschen
damit zu tun dass tricky in englisch ja
eigentlich truthahn heißt und so wollte
man offenbar wollte erdogan nicht mehr
sein land genannt haben wissen deswegen
ist eben das offiziell auch hier bei der
nato jetzt neuer sprachgebrauch aber es
hatte nicht unmittelbar mit diesen
verhandlungen zu tun und wie spricht man
jetzt richtig aus
ob wir in amerika sagen alle weiterhin
turkey auch ganz anders geschrieben wird
okay wir sind gleich wieder bei dir
immer egon ramms ist bei uns sie waren
einer der höchsten rang hohen soldaten
der nato ist das für sie heute ein guter
tag weil dem militärbündnis quasi wieder
neues leben eingehaucht wird oder ein
schlechter tag weil er zeigt in welche
sicherheitspolitisch schwierigen zeiten
wir leben
also das ist ein guter tag nicht weil
dem militärbündnis neues leben
eingehaucht worden ist die einst
statements die von hirntod ordinarius
überholt gesprochen haben haben ja nicht
der realität entsprochen vor allen
dingen auch zu dem zeitpunkt nicht mehr
der realität entsprochen die nato hat
immer in ihrer geschichte aufs und ups
gehabt das ist glaube ich normal für
eine so große organisation aber tatsache
ist halt ganz einfach dass die nato mit
dem heutigen gipfel tag und auch der
fortsetzung morgen ja in eine neue zeit
rein geht mit einem neuen strategischen
konzept und dieses alles führt dazu dass
die nato auch als politisches
militärbündnis wieder eine andere rolle
spielt als sie vielleicht eine zeit lang
gespielt als wir uns auf
auslandseinsätze konzentriert haben eine
frage von ronny norbert über youtube
geht direkt an sie wie hoch schätzen sie
die wahrscheinlichkeit eines russischen
angriff auf nato territorium in den
kommenden jahren ein
also diese einschätzung von meiner seite
ist sehr niedrig das ist meine
persönliche bewertungen die kann ich
nicht belegen sonntag spielen
erfahrungen und ich sag mal was
verhalten an rolle mit ich kann mir
einfach nicht vorstellen dass russland
oder wladimir punkt - riskieren wird die
nato in einen krieg hinein zu ziehen
oder zu einem krieg herauszufordern
thema nato territorium angreift um diese
politik der nato die ihr seit vier
monaten sehr konsequent verfolgt wird
von allen nato gremien einschließlich
den generalsekretär wird ihn davon
abhalten über die nato grenzen hinweg
anzugreifen thema wie wird das bei dir
auf diesem gipfel besprochen spürt man
da so etwas über in den unterhaltungen
dass man das doch anders einschätzt dass
die sorge da ist dass ein solcher
angriff realistisch sein könnte hat
jetzt die gefahr real sein könnte
also wir haben ja in den vergangenen
monaten gesehen dass einige staaten auf
genau grund dieser sorge dann auch
geschaut haben ob man nicht irgendwelche
verhandlungsangebote an wladimir putin
machen müsste damit der krieg sich nicht
am ende doch noch weiter ausweitet ich
glaube das ist aber vom tisch man hat
sich sowohl beim g7-gipfel als auch bei
der nato hier für geschlossene
entschlossenheit oder entschlossene
geschlossenheit entschieden und das
sieht man eben bei dem was hier gemacht
wird die verstärkung der amerikanischen
truppenpräsenz ist natürlich ein signal
dass man immer noch auch ein stückweit
befürchtungen hat da wird eine
militärbasis der usa in polen entstehen
da kommen f 35 kampfjets nach
großbritannien zwei weitere
kriegsschiffe nach spanien zwei neue
flugabwehrsysteme nach deutschland und
italien verbunden auch mit soldaten also
über 600 zusätzliche us soldaten in
deutschland also man will abschreckend
von einer möglichen ausweitung des
konfliktes man traut putin sicherlich
auch zu dass er vielleicht es machen
würde oder wollte aber man glaubt nicht
ernsthaft dass er dazu in der lage wäre
weil das russische militär das sagt die
amerikanische seite ganz klar ist nicht
nur in der ukraine momentan heftig
gebunden sondern tatsächlich verschießt
all ihre munition wird schwierigkeiten
haben waffen und munition nachzuliefern
insofern möglicherweise gar nicht in der
lage der nato in irgendeiner weise
tatsächlich ernsthaft gefährlich zu
werden aber man geht hier auf nummer
sicher
man sieht ja auch an der reaktion des
russischen stellvertretenden
außenministers sergej rjabkow der heute
gesagt hat das gipfeltreffen in madrid
festigt den kurs einer aggressiven
eindämmung russlands durch die
militärallianz in kourou so schreibt
über facebook ihre sorge vielleicht an
sie heran 300.000 soldaten anstelle
40.000 ist das ein guter deeskalation
plan was tut man dafür dass der krieg
ein ende nimmt was tut man dass wir
nicht in den krieg gezogen werden
es geht im augenblick glaube ich nicht
um deeskalation denn ich wüsste nicht
wie man putin
herunterfahren kann so dass er sich mit
vernünftigen verhandlungs vorstellungen
am verhandlungstisch sitzt ich neige da
ein bisschen zu der auffassung
beispielsweise der staats und
regierungschefs
der baltischen staaten und polen für
eine zeit lang in polen stationiert und
ich habe damals erlebt dass es durchaus
sinnvoll ist wenn man sich mit großen
verhandlungstisch setzen will dass bei
einer harte und feste position hat und
das ist das was die nato auch mit diesem
gipfel unterstreicht es ist notwendig
wir werden irgendwann zum thema
verhandlungen diplomatie zurückkehren
müssen dass es sicherlich richtig aber
aus einer schwachen position mit
russland entfernten umzugehen macht
keinen sinn ich würde auch diese zahl
300.000 gerne mal etwas relativieren das
sind soldaten die sind heute schon da
die werden jetzt nicht neu aus dem boden
gestampft sie müssen nur mit einer
wesentlich höheren einsatzbereitschaft
als die bisher gehabt haben zur
verfügung stehen früher unter dem alten
strategischen konzept und dem verfahren
der nato war der tories pons force weil
er so was wir zeiten gehabt haben von 30
tagen 90 tagen 180 tagen ist die
einsatzbereitschaft hergestellt werden
sollte und dieses verkürzt sich jetzt
auf einen zeitraum von ich sage mal
zwischen 55 tagen und daher ist hier ein
größerer zeitdruck drin das hat aber
auch andere konsequenzen es hat zum
beispiel die konsequenz dass die
streitkräfte die wir haben voll
ausgestattet sein müssen personell voll
aufgestellt sein müssen und entsprechend
gut ausgebildet sein müssen das heißt
die forderung hier an die nato
mitgliedsstaaten werden deutlich höher
als die bisher gewesen aber es ist keine
bodentruppen vermehrung wir sprechen
gleich noch mal im detail darüber was
das auch für die bundeswehr bedeutet und
welche anforderungen das bedeutet immer
blicken wir noch einmal auf eine
mögliche reformbedürftigkeit der nato
wenn man sieht dass vom veto des
türkischen präsidenten so viel abhängt
weil es eben auch ein
einstimmigkeitsprinzip ist gibt es nicht
an dieser stelle
reformbedarf weil man merkt was passiert
welche macht ein player bekommen kann
wenn er bestimmte entscheidungen des
bündnisses blockieren möchte
ja dass schwingt natürlich im
hintergrund bei allem eigentlich mit
muss man nicht irgendwann auch mal dann
eine grenze ziehen was einzelne
mitglieder boykottieren können aber das
ist natürlich ein zweischneidiges
schwert denn es gibt eben auch andere
themen wo einzelne staaten darunter zum
beispiel auch deutschland vielleicht
eine andere meinung vertreten ich will
mal das beispiel von heute nennen wir
wissen dass hinter den kulissen heftig
diskutiert worden ist ob man china in
der im strategiepapier als bedrohung
tatsächlich bezeichnet da waren die usa
und einer reihe verbündeten sehr stark
dafür weil sie sagen china ist ganz klar
eine bedrohung nicht nur weil es
gemeinsam mit russland die rechte
basierte weltordnung untergräbt ist
erpresst seine nachbarn aber auch andere
staaten die wirtschaftlich von china
abhängig sind es droht militärisch
gegenüber taiwan aber auch anderen im
indopazifik in dieser region und vor
diesem hintergrund wollte man
reinschreiben china ist eine bedrohung
sich vernetzen mit den pazifischen
bündnissen aber gleichzeitig haben
deutschland die bundesregierung und
einige andere ganz offenbar das
verhindert und haben gesagt nein soweit
sollten wir nicht gehen china ist ein
anderes kaliber als
russland russland zeigt gerade ja die
aggression in einem krieg also hat man
sich am ende geeinigt auf das wort
herausforderung also vor diesem
hintergrund ist am ende die aufgabe des
einstimmigkeitsprinzips
eine schwierige sache und ich glaube das
wird jetzt nicht anfangen und am
fallschirm am ende sich dann wirklich
verändern hierbei datum
motive sind vielen dank für diese
einschätzungen nach madrid danke schön
dass du den nato-gipfel von dort für uns
mit begleitet hast damit gebe ich eine
nächste frage an herrn rams weil rtw
sind das thema china gerade angesprochen
hat und ich sehe dass das in den chat
eine große rolle spielt gibt driver
fragt zum beispiel sollten wir nicht
auch die chinesen im auge behalten die
sind meiner meinung nach ebenso wenn ich
noch gefährlicher als die russen danke
für eine antwort und
endlos blogspot channel schreibt besteht
die gefahr dass china russland im krieg
gegen die ukraine aktiv unterstützen
wird mit waffenlieferungen geld et
cetera wie es ihrer einschätzung was
china angeht
zunächst sollten das im alten
strategischen konzept von 2010 china
nicht einmal erwähnt gewesen ist und
auch dieser streit über bedrohung oder
herausforderung zeigt dass man sich
china entsprechend zuwendet ich sage
dass man unter beobachtung stellt aber
nicht als einen potenziellen gegner oder
eine bedrohung markiert die russland
zurzeit aufgrund des angriffskrieges in
der ukraine
der erste sei nicht sehr wichtige teil
der schlicht und einfach festhalten muss
der zweite punkt ist der china macht
weltpolitik und macht vor allen dingen
welthandel und china wird alles
unterlassen was den welthandel zu
gunsten von china in aller form
beeinträchtigen wird von daher ist china
in diese richtung moderator ich glaube
sogar dass china trotz der in
zusammenarbeit mit russland ein
korrektiv und ein korrekturfaktor für
russland sein kann stichwort nukleare
drohung ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass die ping als der chinesische
staatsführer putin ermutigen würde mit
nuklearsprengköpfen zu arbeiten bzw
nuklear sprengkörper zu zünden oder
dergleichen mehr und china hat ja zu
anfang dieses krieges auch ein etwas ich
sag das mal vorsichtig an die wir
ambivalente position gezeigt die sich
dann allerdings hinter zugunsten von
russland verschoben hat aber ohne aktive
unterstützung für russland zu leisten
von daher mit blick auf das stativ
strategische konzept die nato hat diesen
punkt erkannt die nato wird sich um
diesen punkt kümmern
und die nato wird china entsprechend ich
sag das mal vorsichtig beobachten und
sehen wie die entwicklung dort
weitergeht und dann kann man ja
möglicherweise mit weiteren politischen
entscheidungen im bereich der nato
politischen entscheidungen und dann
hinter auch militärischen konsequenzen
dort weiter handlungsfähig bleiben
vielleicht noch ein wort zum
konsens prinzip in der nato ich möchte
aber noch mal deutlich unterstreichen
dass in einem solchen bündnis die
einzelmitglieder staaten ja für
bestimmte politische richtung auch
korrektive sein können und das hat bei
der nato und ich bisher immer
funktioniert
dann schauen wir auf das was die
bundeswehr nun zu leisten hat es gibt
besondere herausforderungen was personal
material aufrüstung infrastruktur angeht
der vorsitzende des deutschen bundes
verbundes wer verbands andré wüstner hat
mit blick auf das 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen heute noch einmal gesagt
wie es auch im fußball so schön heißt
geld allein schießt keine tore sondern
die bundeswehr muss sich jetzt auch was
führung und management angeht gut
aufstellen was bedeutet diese nato
neuausrichtung für die bundeswehr
also die belastung im rahmen der nato
verpflichtung für die bundesrichter
deutschland werden größer werden das
bedeutet auch dass zum beispiel das
personelle ziel welches mal durch frau
von der leyen als
verteidigungsministerin gesetzt worden
ist von 203.000 erreicht werden muss uns
fehlen da zurzeit 20.000 soldaten die
wir dringend brauchen die geworben
werden müssten die mit der
entsprechenden attraktivität des berufes
dann hoffentlich auch zur bundeswehr
kommen das ist der eine teil dabei der
zweite teil ist der dass wir ja
zeitweilig mit ich sag das mal viel
material planmäßig gearbeitet haben das
ist ein zustand der muss in jedem falle
abgestellt werden die truppenteile die
wir haben müssen voll ausgestattet
werden sie müssen über ihr großgerät
verfügen sie müssen ihre ausrüstung
verfügen sie müssen über die
entsprechende munition verfügen auch das
ist eine aufgabe mit blick auf munitions
neubeschaffungen die erst geleistet
werden muss und die nicht wie man das
häufig in der politik glaubt oder auch
in den medien glaubt mit einem
fingerschnippen erledigt wird sondern
das sind prozesse die dauern auch ihre
zeit von daher das geld ist angebracht
es muss genutzt werden dafür um die
einsatzbereitschaft der bundeswehr
ich sag das mal deutlich zu steigern
die personal noch eine aussage dazu wir
haben ja bitte das heißt die frage des
users app wilo kann die bundeswehr die
nato ziele überhaupt in der zeit
umsetzen bzw ihren entsprechenden
beitrag leisten die würden sie mit einem
vorsichtigen ja beantworten
mit einem positiven jahr das war eine
kutsche formulierung vorstellen wird ja
es bedarf dazu entsprechende
anstrengungen die müssen geleistet
werden und wenn die geleistet werden
auch finanziell geleistet werden aber
auch vor allen dingen personell
geleistet werden dann hat die bundeswehr
sehr wohl die möglichkeit diese
forderung zu erfüllen
sie wollten noch eine ergänzung zum
personal machen und dann erweitern wir
den blick noch mal und blicken auf die
ukrainische sicht der dinge
also zum personal noch eine anmerkung
wir haben wie ich gerade gesagt habe
rund 183000 soldaten wir wollen nein wir
müssen auf 203.000 um die truppenteile
entsprechend personell aufzufüllen und
das personal auch für zusätzliche
aufgaben zur verfügung zu stellen die
bundeswehr muss ihre fähigkeiten
ausbauen der sage mal schwierige teil um
dieses zu erreichen ist das personal das
personal muss geworben werden und ich
hoffe ein wenig dass diese diskussion
die wir zurzeit führen auch aufgrund des
nato gipfels aber aufgrund der ganzen
entwicklung von der ukraine seit dem 4
hinter ukraine seit dem 24 februar dazu
führen dass das interesse in der
bevölkerung an ihrer bundeswehr wieder
größer wird und wir dann auch wieder
mehr freiwillige soldaten bekommen so
dass wir die stärke von 203.000
tatsächlich erreichen können unser
vielleicht mal ein freundliches take you
for your service wie es in den
amerikanischen bundesstaaten übliches
wenn man einen soldaten trifft wenn man
in der bahn vielleicht einen
bundeswehrsoldaten trifft ein bisschen
anerkennung zeigen für den dienst den er
leistet wir haben heute den ukrainischen
präsidenten zu sehen der wir erlauben ja
wenn sie mir erlauben möchte ich gebe
noch eine kleine aussage hinzufügen
präsident kennedy hat während seiner
amtszeit als präsident gesagt denke
nicht darüber nach was dein land für
dich tun kann sondern denkt darüber nach
was du für dein land tun kannst das war
ein grund sei dass in deutschland den
letzten jahren etwas weit in den
hintergrund getreten
der ukrainische präsident hat sehr dazu
aufgefordert mehr für sein land zu tun
das hat er heute noch mal beim
nato-gipfel betonten mehr waffen
modernere ausrüstung auch mehr geld hat
er gefordert denn die russischen
angriffe gehen weiter wie zuletzt auf
ein einkaufszentrum in krementschouk
stefan ress berichtet
ganz in der nähe des einkaufszentrums
der moment als die rakete einschlägt
aufgenommen von überwachungskameras nur
irgendwie in sicherheit bringen das
eigene leben retten
diese chance hatten viele die hier zum
einkaufen waren nicht mindestens 20
menschen sterben hat die rakete
einschlägt mehr als 50 werden verletzt
ich dachte ich fliege überall spürte ich
splitter in meinem körper das ganze
gebäude explodierte es fiel alles in
sich zusammen
unter den trümmern werden noch bis zu 60
menschen vermutet wegen luftalarm
mussten die bergungsarbeiten zwischen
durch stundenlang unterbrochen werden
die russische armee räumt den angriff
zwar ein er habe aber einen benachbarten
waffen und munitionsdepot gegolten und
nicht im einkaufszentrum der ukrainische
präsident widerspricht das sei ein
absichtlicher angriff gewesen sagte er
in einer botschaft an den un
sicherheitsrat
er forderte ein tribunal dass das
russische vorgehen untersuchen soll
schulen theater wohngebäude und jetzt
ein einkaufszentrum seit beginn des
krieges wurden unzählige zivile ziele
von russischen raketen getroffen
tja und da zu jagen nach weil lück wahl
von unserem korrespondenten in kiew der
uns jetzt auch hören kann glück was sind
denn die erwartungen der ukraine an
diesen gibt es vor dem hintergrund
dessen was wir gerade auch im stück von
stefan ress noch mal gesehen haben die
angriffe gehen unvermindert weiter
ja es klang ja schon in den gesprächen
mit mrt wissen und auch dem ex
bundeswehr general an die ukraine
erwartet ganz klar eine fähige und
effiziente luft ab wäre das kann sie
selber nicht stellen wenn man sich die
situation hier im land mal anschaut dann
gab es allein in den letzten vier tagen
mehr als 130 raketentreffer raketen oder
cruise missile treffer und zwar nicht an
der front von der wir jeden tag
berichten nämlich in lugansk oder im
gebiet lugansk und dann jetzt sondern im
hinterland allein heute wurden vier
städte getroffen odessa danny
pro-aktiv und nikolajew wo mindestens
fünf menschen starben als ein wohnhaus
getroffen wurde und die ukraine ist ein
stückweit diesen angriffen hilflos
ausgesetzt daneben wie ich eben sagte
geht eben der heftige kampf direkt an
der frontlinie in den umkämpften
gebieten im haus in der ost ukraine
weiter und da wird die startliste
zunehmend eingekesselt von russischen
truppen die langsam aber stetig
vorrücken und vor allen dingen auf die
hauptstraße dem letzten verbindungsglied
vorrücken dass diese eingekesselte stadt
lugansk noch mit den verbindungswegen
also auch mit munitions nachschub und
möglichen fluchtwege verbindet also
diese hauptstraße ist heftig umkämpft
fazit sein ski hat das heute gesagt die
ukraine braucht natürlich auch geld er
hat gesagt sie haben einen multi
millionen dollar defizit allein
viereinhalb milliarden euro auch der
staat hier jeden monat weil er das gar
nicht tragen kann die kriegskosten man
muss ja auch bedenken dass der krieg vor
allen dingen da tobt wo das industrielle
herz der ukraine geschlagen hat und
viele dieser anlagen sind zerstört wir
haben das gesehen bei so stahl wir haben
es auch gesehen bei dem chemiewerk als
ort und da kommt einfach kein geld mehr
zusammen und daneben eben dringend mehr
munition
mehr schwerer artillerie und vor allen
dingen eine effiziente luftabwehr
die ukraine oder der ukrainische
präsident hofft dass der krieg vor
beginn des winters beendet ist was
bräuchte denn bevor ich an rams frage
was die nato überhaupt geben könnte aber
was bräuchte denn die ukraine damit
dieser krieg bis zum winter vorbei ist
also das ist sicherlich
eine aussage von salewski gewesen die er
auch gesprochen hat um den menschen mut
zu machen das liegt an der front im
moment nicht wirklich gut aus für die
ukraine und viele fragen sich wo soll
das enden wo wird das überhaupt enden
und deswegen auch diese äußerungen von
selen ski und dass man sich vorher sagte
ist ein erster schritt das müsste
zunächst einmal sichergestellt werden
dass diese gezielten und wiederholten
angriffe aus der luft die ja nicht
direkt von den frontlinien der russen
gestattet werden sondern die werden aus
sicheren gebieten gestartet teilweise
von bombern die ausbilder russ staaten
oder über dem schwarzen oder kaspischen
meer
dagegen müsste sich die ukraine
verteidigen können um überhaupt eine
chance zu haben
noch gar nicht in den angriff zu gehen
aber zumindest die vorrückenden
russischen truppen zu stoppen und vor
allen dingen diese luftangriffe eben
einzustellen und damit eine gewisse
stabilität im hinterland zu bringen das
ist im moment nicht da das wurde
versprochen also eben heute hat zum
beispiel norwegen aber auch deutschland
und die niederlande angekündigt sie
werden sehr effiziente luftabwehrsysteme
liefern drei stück an der zahl aus
norwegen 3 aus deutschland das reicht
natürlich nicht die usa hat angekündigt
ein 450 millionen dollar paket auch da
sollen effiziente luftabwehrraketen
dabei sein die frage ist wann kommt das
wie schnell kommt dass und in dieser
zeit fliegen die russen natürlich ihre
angriffe weiter also dieser termin vor
dem winter ist sicherlich auch ein stück
psychologie die ukraine braucht im
moment jede aufmunterung die sie
bekommen kann und dann ist eben dieser
winter auch das problem wir haben heute
mit dem chef des staatlichen
energiekonzerns naftogaz gesprochen und
er hat klar gesagt der winter wird uns
vor probleme stellen es ist ganz klar
russland kann das gas komplett abstellen
im moment schließt noch gas aus russland
wenn auch nicht in der vorgegebenen
menge aber es die ukraine bekommt noch
gas aus russland
aber das kann jederzeit abbestellt
werden und deswegen ist die ukraine zum
beispiel bei dem strengen winter der vor
der tür steht auch angewiesen
möglicherweise aufs gas lieferungen so
komisch das klingen mag aus europa und
aus dem westen und das in einer
situation wo europa selbst zu wenig gas
hat
herr rams hier fragt ein user namens
eric smax sollte man nicht mehr schwere
waffen aus nato beständen liefern die
nato ist doch in konventioneller
kriegsführung ohnehin überlegen im
zweiten weltkrieg gab es dafür ein leih
und pacht gesetz damals
die aussage mit dem neu entfacht gesetz
zwischen
damaligen sowjetunion und den
vereinigten staaten von amerika ist
zutreffend ich wüsste nicht wer der
partner der ukraine sein sollte und
möchte einen wichtigen hinweis geben wir
reden immer kann die nato nicht helfen
bei den waffenlieferungen
ich möchte darauf hinweisen
nachdrücklich darauf hinweisen dass
diese waffenlieferung von den nationen
erfolgen und letztendlich mit der
funktion der nato und der nato relativ
wenig zu tun haben das sind die
einzelstaaten die liefern und die
einzelstaaten bringen die waffensysteme
dahin und hier gibt es für mich eine
klare vor schluss folgerung die trifft
viele nato-mitglieder sie trifft auch
deutschland nachdem der krieg begonnen
hat haben wir zu spät angefangen darüber
nachzudenken waffen zu liefern und die
entscheidungsprozesse waren zum teil zu
lang und das ist der grund warum viele
von den waffen zugesagt sind auch noch
nicht da sind auch er ist von den
norwegern oder weitere flugabwehrsysteme
die aufgrund der luftüberlegenheit
russlands sehr sehr wichtig sind stehen
auch dort morgen nicht vor natürlich
sage das in aller deutlichkeit von daher
muss dieser fluss der unterstützung für
die ukraine mit munition mit gilt aber
auch vor allen dingen mit waffen mit
denen man sich gegenüber den russen zur
wehr setzen kann sinnvoll zur wehr
setzen kann der muss fortgesetzt werden
erlauben so noch eine anmerkung zu dem
einkaufszentrum
ich finde das zynisch wenn der russische
generalstab bekannt gibt
nach dem mann festgestellt das hat
tatsächlich dieses einkaufszentrum
getroffen dass man einen beabsichtigt
ein benachbartes militärlager treffen
wollte dann ist das für mich der blanke
zynismus nach dem motto wir haben uns
verschossen tut uns fürchterlich leid
das ist nicht hinnehmbar von da sind die
äußerungen die präsident zu lenski zu
diesem thema vor dem un-sicherheitsrat
gemacht hat zu 100 prozent zu treffen
und richtig es gibt hier in den chats
verschiedentlich
ich nenne das jetzt mal tatsächlich
schon verschwörungstheoretiker ansätze
in der frage warum so wenig waffen oder
nicht so viele waffen wie gewünscht aus
dem westen in die ukraine kommen anne
rabe fragt zum beispiel moderne
waffenlieferungen sind bisher nur zu
spät oder im geringen umfang
durchgeführt worden ist es eine
strategie die ukraine zur aufgabe des
donbass zu zwingen und tom frank fragt
auch über youtube in dieselbe richtung
wie so liefert der westen bis jetzt
keine modernen waffen was steckt
dahinter
herr am soll dahinter steckt zum einen
die tatsache ja dahinter steckt zum
einen die tatsache dass man lange zeit
angst gehabt hat dass wir mit
unmittelbar aus dem westen
beispielsweise aus der bundesrepublik
nach in die ukraine gelieferte waffen
die eskalation schwelle überschreiten
könnte so das protein weitere maßnahmen
auch gegenüber nato territorium
durchführen würde was ich nicht glaube
ich glaube dass diese angst nicht
begründet war auf der anderen seite muss
man staats und regierungschefs zu
würdigen dass sie sich wirklich
intensive gedanken darüber machen müssen
wie sie sich nicht in einen krieg
hineinziehen lassen was ja auch die nato
mit den entsprechenden maßnahmen getan
hat und die staaten haben sicherlich in
der richtung auch gehandelt vielleicht
gehört aber auch mit zu dass wir nach
dem
russland kiew nicht hat einnehmen können
um die regierung nicht hat stürzen
können vielleicht ein bisschen von
euphorie über die kampfkraft der
ukrainischen streitkräfte
gezehrt haben wobei die kampfkraft und
die kampfmoral der ukrainischen
streitkräfte kann so hoch sein wie sie
will wenn sie keine munition mehr haben
sind ihre kriegshandlung zu ende das
heißt es ist eine aufgabe des westens
noch verstärkter aufgabe auch bei einer
kürzeren zeit achse so schnell wie
möglich waffen dorthin zulief liefern
und auch diese schöne geschichte vor dem
ringtausch wird irgendwann aufgrund
nicht mehr verfügbaren ehemaligen
sowjetischen oder russischen materials
bei unseren östlichen nachbarstaaten
irgendwann zu ende sein und dann wird
man politisch die entscheidung fällen
müssen ob man kampfpanzer leopard 1
schützenpanzer vielleicht sogar
kampfpanzer leopard 2 an die ukraine
wird liefern müssen oder die dritte
möglichkeit wäre die dass man sagen
müsste dafür stellen müsste man hat hier
mit gespaltener zunge gesprochen was ich
nicht glaube einfach aus dem grunde weil
ich glaube dass die unsere politik sich
darüber im klaren ist dass die freiheit
demokratischer staaten und
rechtsstaatlichkeit derzeit in der
ukraine gegen einen aggressor der kaum
noch kalkulierbar ist verteidigt wird
und das sollten wir nutzen das ist eine
gelegenheit für uns letztendlich die
ukraine in diesem krieg zu unterstützen
sagt egon ramms ländern scheint die
sonne in kiew regnet deshalb letzte
frage an dich lücke nach dem was egon
ramms gerade gesagt hat man muss sich
bewusst machen dass die westliche
freiheit in der ukraine verteidigt wird
was ist das heute für ein tag für die
ukraine ein tag wo man sieht okay es
gibt jetzt wieder ein starkes bündnis
das es gut denn es gibt eine eine
politische entscheidung militärisch
russland etwas entgegenzusetzen oder ist
das ein schlechter tag weil das eben ein
bündnis ist an dem die ukraine nicht
teil hat
ich glaube für die ukraine ist jeder tag
der aus dem ausland unterstützung für
diesen verzweifelten kampf gegen die
übermächtige russische armee
signalisiert ein guter tag
ich denke ein stückweit general franz
hat das ja angedeutet wir haben ja auch
deswegen so lange gezögert weil man in
europäischen hauptstädten auch in berlin
lange der ansicht war das ist
möglicherweise zu riskant mit voller
macht sich gegen diese russische armee
zu stellen inzwischen glaube ich denkt
man da um weil man sieht dass putin für
andere argumente offenbar kaum noch
zugänglich ist insofern bleibt wohl nur
die militärische auseinandersetzung und
hier in der ukraine ist es so dass man
lange und zwar lange vor beginn dieses
kriegs auch praktisch seit annexion der
krim und seit dem scheitern
der letzten endes der beiden minz
abkommen der ansicht ist dass die nato
die entwicklung verschlafen hatte und
putin zu blauäugig gesehen hat und
insofern ist man verzweifelt lange vor
diesen krieg inzwischen hat man aber
keine zeit mehr für diese verzweiflung
man muss sich praktisch jeden tag gegen
den feind stellen und hoffen dass er
nicht noch weiter vorrückt und nicht
noch mehr zerstört insofern ist man froh
über jedes unterstützungs zeichen und
auch jede jeden schuss munition und
jeder achte rakete die hier noch ankommt
vielen dank rückwardt grüße gehen an
dieser stelle raus noch an dich von mozy
beschreibt respekt an den reporter der
in kiew ist das wollen wir hier sehr
gerne weitergeben vielen dank glück war
bot vielen dank egon ramms dass sie
heute nicht bei uns in der sendung waren
und vielen dank liebe userinnen und user
auch heute abend wieder fürs mit schauen
mitdenken und mit kommentieren wir sagen
tschüss und bis zum nächsten mal einen
schönen amt